today on the matt wall show we will talk
about the incredible toll the lockdowns
have taken on our children
at least as at least one school district
is rushing to reopen in response to a
surge in childhood suicides
also five headlines including biden
admitting that nothing we do will change
the trajectory of the virus
so then why does he want to wear a mask
for 100 days if it's not going to change
anything plus
an msnbc analyst tries to make a
profound point by extensively quoting a
nicki minaj lyric and
in our daily cancellation yet another
tick-tock parent is on the slate
to be canceled that and much more today
on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know one of the biggest win-wins as
as i'm always telling you about one of
the biggest win-wins that you can
ask for is to be able to support a
company
that provides a valuable service but
also supports
your values and is working for you
and your belief system in the culture
and that's why you've got to check out
charity mobile
um charity mobile it's called the
pro-life phone company there's a reason
for that it's at five percent of your
monthly plan plan price goes to the
pro-life pro family charity of your
choice
uh there's also a lot of other stuff
that comes with it they have a live
customer service based right here in the
usa if you ever have anything you need
and if you want to just check out
charity mobile try the service out
and you don't want to make a commitment
right away that's fine because there's
no contracts there's no termination fees
there's no risk with a 30-day guarantee
also new activations and eligible
accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
you get free usage alerts you get an app
to monitor your usage pay your bills a
lot more
and that's really convenient as well and
the entire time you are helping to build
a culture of life in america while
supporting a pro-life phone company
charity mobile is what i use um and
it's what you should use as well you can
turn everyday living into effortless
giving for the charity of your choice
also you get nationwide service on
america's largest and most reliable 4g
lte network
if you want all that and who doesn't
call them at 1-877-474-3662 or chat with
them online at charitymobile.com
much of the conversation about the
lockdowns over the past 10 months has
focused on the question of whether they
are actually the best way to slow the
spread of the virus
uh that's been you know that's been the
be all and end all of the conversation
but this has always
overshadowed and obscured the more
important question which is whether
slowing the spread of the virus should
be the overarching
number one priority of our entire
society relegating all other concerns to
secondary status
is stopping people from getting the
virus in fact
so important that any other cost they
might have to bear as a result for our
measure of our measures will be worth it
you know that is and has always been the
real question
and it's not a scientific question
that's the thing it's more it's more of
a philosophical question
it's a question of priority um
of importance of risk versus reward cost
and benefit
see this transcends statistics it's not
something you can figure out by looking
at a spreadsheet
it's not something that a a guy like
anthony fauci
will necessarily have anything useful to
say about
and that's why the powers that be did
not want the issue framed this way
they only wanted us to ever consider the
first question which is
will the lockdowns stop people from
getting sick
all other considerations be damned all
other questions are moot they claimed
and they are and we're always wrong
about that
which brings us to a rare event over the
weekend the new york times published
some actual journalism for a change the
story by erica green
reports on the decision to get schools
in clark county nevada las vegas
opened again as soon as possible and
what's prompted
this urgent rush to reopen schools is a
surge in suicides among children in the
area
let's read now from the piece a little
bit it says since schools shut their
doors in march an early warning system
that monitors students mental health
episodes has
sent more than 3 100 alerts to district
officials
raising alarms about suicidal thoughts
possible self-harm or cries for care
by december 18 students had taken their
own lives
the spate of student suicides in and
around las vegas has
pushed the clark county district the
nation's fifth largest
toward bringing students back as quickly
as possible this month the school board
gave the green light to phase in the
return of some elementary school grades
and groups of struggling students
even as greater las vegas continues to
post huge numbers of coronavirus death
cases
superintendents across the nation are
weighing the benefit of in-person
education against the cost of public
health
watching teachers and staff become sick
and in case in some cases die but also
seeing the psychological and academic
toll
that school closings are having on
children nearly a year in
the risk of student suicides has quietly
stirred many district leaders leading
some
like the state superintendent in arizona
to cite that fear in public please to
help mitigate the viruses spread
now the piece continues by looking at
the larger suicide trend which it admits
it's hard to quantify because we don't
have national data on suicides in the
year 2020 yet
even so it says quote one study from the
cdc
uh shows that the percentage of youth
emergency room visits that were for
mental health reasons had risen
during the pandemic the actual number of
those visits fell
the researchers noted that many people
were avoiding hospitals
that were dealing with the crush of
chronovirus patients and at a
compilation of emergency calls in more
than 40 states among all age groups
showed increased numbers related to
mental health
in clark county 18 suicides over nine
months of closure is double
the nine the district had the entire
previous year
six students died by suicide between
march 16th and june 30th
12 students died by suicide between july
1st and december 31st
one student left a note saying he had
nothing to look forward to the youngest
student
dr jarrah has lost to suicide was nine
okay nine years old so think about that
my oldest kids the twins are seven seven
and a half really um
not that far from that age a child so
young committing suicide is
it's literally unthinkable you can't
wrap your head around it
and of course we can't know specifically
what drove any of these kids to this
point
it would seem safe to assume that many
of these children whether in clark
county or elsewhere
had other things going on in their lives
in addition to the lockdowns
which may have contributed though again
we can't know
but anytime a nine-year-old kills
themselves
that should be an occasion for the whole
country to stop in its tracks
and ask what the hell is going on how
could there be children
so young and yet in such a desperate
psychological state
now you could point out here that
suicide rates among children have been
rising across the country
before the lockdowns were imposed before
cover 19 existed way before
a report from from pbs in 2019 had these
findings that said between 2000 2007
the suicide rate among youth ages 10 to
24
hovered around 6.8 deaths per t per 100
000 people
then the rate curved upward reaching a
rate of 10.6 deaths
per 100 000 by 2017 a 56 increase in
less than two decades
says by the year 2017 um suicide was the
second leading cause of death among
americans aged 15 to 24 to put that in
context
suicide is the 10th leading cause of
death among americans in general of all
ages
so this is clearly a problem that
predates the lockdowns but that only
further proves
why the lockdowns were a disastrous
mistake
especially with respect to schools
whatever the reasons and the reasons are
various and complex
there was already a crisis of despair
and hopelessness among children they
were already vulnerable
and now you lock them in their homes for
months on end
rip them out of their routines take away
their friends take away their social
gatherings
instill in them a deep fear over a virus
that poses very little risk to them
personally
force them to be muzzled when they go
out in public
deprive them of the chance to even see
the faces of strangers when they're out
in public
i mean how do you think that's going to
end what other result could it possibly
have
but this and this is why i say the
spreadsheets and the statistics and the
bar graphs
miss the point this is why lockdown
critics are not denying the science
we're accused of well you're denying the
science
our point is that the most important
questions don't have anything to do
with the science the science is beside
the point
and if you disagree if that scandalizes
you hear someone say the science is
beside the point
okay well then tell me scientifically
what is the reduction in cases the exact
number
that makes even one childhood suicide
worth the cost
if you're telling me this is a
scientific question well then go ahead
spock make it scientific
tell me how spell it out for me
take just the child who said that he uh
who killed himself
before that said that he he you know he
missed his friends and he
missed how things were before how many
alleged lives
saved from the lockdowns make that worth
the cost
what is the scientific answer to that
question there isn't one
because this is a moral question as i
said a philosophical one
and my moral and philosophical answer is
that there is
no reduction in cases no slowing of the
spread
that can make one child suicide worth it
that's my answer what we're doing to our
children right now
the damage we are doing nothing can make
that worth it
nothing now you could disagree if you
want
but say me the crap about i'm following
the science
this has not a damn thing to do with the
science
it's about priorities i believe
our priority as a society should always
be
always be protecting our children
that should always be our number one
priority as a society
is that what the science says no the
science doesn't say a damn thing about
what our priorities should be
as a society that's what human beings
are supposed to say
and that's what makes us all the more
disgraceful you know we have seen a
total inversion of priorities
this virus was never a great threat to
children
so we have done all of this to protect
ourselves we have asked or demanded
really that our kids
our kids our kids make the sacrifices
even even bear the brunt of the
sacrifices
so that we can be safe
this is exactly the opposite of what we
are meant to do
you know societies can be judged by how
they treat their children i believe that
and we were already failing enormously
by that measure 60 million kids killed
since roe v wade so we were already a
failure in that regard
but now after this i mean what will
future generations say about a people
that
drove their own kids to suicide in order
to protect
themselves from a virus
they won't say anything good we can
assume that the judgment on us by
history will be
incredibly harsh and we will deserve
all of it now let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
so you know they say honesty is the best
policy but um
sometimes in marriage you know i i do
tend to doubt that a little bit i have
to be honest with you
i'll be honest about that sometimes i
doubt a little bit
i sometimes doubt the honest the the
value of honesty in marriage and i'll
just explain why like for example
yesterday
i got home from traveling i was
traveling over the the weekend
i was in austin and for a pro-life event
actually because they do have those in
austin it turns out it was a great event
anyway i came home
a few hours i thought everything was
fine a few everything looked you know
everything looked normal and the same to
me when i got home
as it did when i left because i left the
day before and
a few hours after i got home my wife
said to me
she said as we're sitting on the couch
um
hey so you didn't say anything about my
hair
and i said and this is where the honesty
kicked in okay this is where i was gonna
be honest and i said
what about your hair and she said i dyed
it
and i said oh and she said
you know it's it's brown now it was
blonde before
and then i said it was blonde before
and then i realized i should stop saying
things in that moment but here's my
point
i was honest for the whole conversation
i was completely honest
now do you really want to tell me that
was the best policy i don't think it was
and then actually in my in my defense i
actually went because i never know when
to drop it so
a little bit later on i went back to try
to prove my point i pulled up her
her profile picture from twitter which
is from before she allegedly
dyed her hair and i showed it to her and
i said no your hair was brown before it
looks the same
i was trying to mansplain her own hair
color to her i was bringing facts
and evidence and destroying her with it
but it didn't matter she said i was
color blind i don't know maybe i am
anyway so keep that in mind just a
little marriage tip let's go here
number one president biden week
had an interesting well interesting
admission
i guess we could say and here it is
let's listen
if we fail to act there will be a wave
of evictions and foreclosures in the
coming months
on as this pandemic grazes on because
there's nothing we can do to change the
trajectory of the pandemic
in the next several months there's
nothing we can do
to change the trajectory of the pandemic
in the next several months that's what
he just said
you know obviously if we had if we got a
media interested in the actual news
this would be like headline news
everywhere
this is a stunning thing for him to say
considering
what his new administration is in the
process of doing like for example
a 100 day mask mandate
everyone wear the mask for 100 days even
though people have already been wearing
a mask for 100 days more than that
um so why are we doing that
as far as i know this question has not
been asked by anybody in the media but
it's like okay well if we can't change a
trajectory
um which by the way i'm not necessarily
i'm not saying i disagree with that
actually but if we can't change the
trajectory
then why are we wearing the mask what is
the point of it exactly if it's not to
change the trajectory i thought that was
the entire point
it's not the point then what are we
doing it for meanwhile a local reporter
in california
uh madario's bab is her name
she has this this is what she reports on
twitter she says i've obtained an email
from the california restaurant
association that says gavin newsom
will be lifting the stay-at-home order
for all regions across the state
tomorrow
and she continues i'm not sure if this
means the region will fall back into the
tier system but no matter what
it would mean less restrictions the cra
says it was informed of the lift today
by newsome administration but the formal
announcement won't be until tomorrow so
the formal announcement will come today
or has already come i don't know
but this is just another
strange coincidence isn't it like as
soon as biden gets into office he says
well there's nothing we can do to change
the trajectory of the virus
didn't say that before and now you have
california they're lifting those state
home restrictions
opening up the restaurants and we we've
seen this really strange coincidence
in uh in states and regions across the
country
and the thing that makes it even more
coincidental i know this is all because
i don't want to get into conspiracy
theorists
theories right i'll be is if you connect
too many dots you're automatically a
conspiracy theorist you know so
that you don't want to be that so i'll
just say it's a it's a
weird coincidence that not only do we
have
these areas opening up as soon as biden
is inaugurated president
the other strange thing is that all the
areas doing this are run by democrats
but who could possibly draw conclusions
no don't be a conspiracy theorist
don't do that it's just it's a
coincidence you know coincidental things
happen
that's all it is number two from the
daily wire says in the past week the
montana house judiciary committee passed
a bill which would create the save
women's sports act
an act that would bar biological boys
from teams or in sports designated for
women or girls
by passing the bill the committee set up
a floor hearing in the montana house the
sponsor of house bill 112
told the montana free press that he
wanted to protect the 1972 title ix
permitting biological boys to compete
against biology girls would be just
wrong he said
so they're passing this bill the reason
i'm reading this story is that
you know this is exactly what states
have to do um
you know it's what been one of my themes
over the last week is
let's let's let's localize our focus
as we have sometimes neglected to do as
conservatives
um and this is one area here now i also
wanted to as we were talking about
because we know the executive order from
biden as we as we're talking about
putting boys into girl sports or into
girl locker rooms
just to demonstrate just the
demonstration
you probably don't need a demonstration
but i'll give it to you anyway because
it's good to have it's good to have the
numbers just in front of you
so to demonstrate why it's insane to
allow
males to compete against girls and
sports and why you need bills like the
one they're passing in montana
um let's go to of a famous example
of boys competing against girls that's
in connecticut where you had
uh andrea yearwood and terry miller
these are both males and i think now
they've graduated but for a couple of
years you know they
both guys and they uh but they they
identified as as girls and they started
running against girls in track and field
okay so here are the results from the
2019
connecticut state championships okay for
for the girls
this is the 55 meter dash
um terry miller and andrea yearwood
for the state championships they both
came in first and second again in the
girls meet
they came in first and second as boys
terry miller was was first uh he had a
6.95 that was his time
andrea yearwood had 7.01
uh and then third quote unquote third
place which is
chelsea mitchell who really was first
place because she's the she is the
she she was the best sprint best the
best female sprinter in the state
in high school was chelsea mitchell but
she came in third place and she had a
7.23
which is significantly behind a 6.95 in
a sprint you know that's
might as well be an eternity okay now
keep those times in mind
you go over to the same year 2019 the
men's
varsity 55 meter dash now this is the
field that miller and yearwood
should have been competing against and
miller came in
in first place against the girls at 6.95
first place for the men's was 6.51
7th place was 6.63
so this is a guy who wouldn't even place
he wouldn't even make it on the track
he probably won't even qualify for the
finals against
the men with his times but against the
girls
he dominates this is a mediocre at best
male athlete male runner who against
females
dominates but if you look at the other
it's it's even more pronounced
like the 300 meter dash terry miller had
a 40.13
enough to beat second place was an
actual girl one second behind again one
second in a dash is is a lot
um but against men the number one time
was 35.11
12 was 37.65 again
wouldn't have even made it on the track
with those times
so you just you cannot look at that and
deny
the biological first of all the
biological difference between between
men and women
and also the fact that just the simple
fact of being
a guy affords you enormous inherent
advantages
that are very very difficult for a woman
to overcome
that a mediocre male athlete or even a
bad
male athlete could just waltz into a
women's sport and take over
casually without even having to work
that hard
all right number three the new york
times um
had this i just thought this was a great
headline
president biden is perhaps the most
religiously observant commander-in-chief
in half a century
a different more liberal christianity
grounds his life and his policies
right which you know i think it's
similar it's
it's it would be like a headline that
said arby's is perhaps the healthiest
restaurant in america
a different more liberal view of
nutrition grounds their recipes and menu
so when you start phrasing things like
that it does you know makes you feel
better about eating at fast food anyway
but this is obviously ridiculous and
we're just no
here's what i'll give you now leaving
aside the fact that as we talked about
last week
joe biden's version of catholicism is
not catholicism at all um he does not
belong to catholicism
he belongs to the the religion of self
really but even putting that aside for a
minute yeah he does go to church and all
that
so at most you could make an argument
that he's the most religiously
observant president of the last three we
had
only because obama and uh and and donald
trump were probably
the least religious presence we ever had
is he more religious than george bush
george bush was condemned repeatedly by
the left
for being like a theocratic fascist like
me
there's no possible way he's more
religious than george bush
but of course we know during the bush
era being religious was a bad thing it
was a bad scary thing
now the biden's in office all of a
sudden it's okay again it's cool to be
religious again
that's big news only don't get too
excited because you have to be the right
kind of religious
which is in the end we find out not
really religious at all
okay number four um this msnbc clip i
want to play for you well i don't know
maybe there shouldn't be any setup you
just have to hear it for yourself let's
listen
and this time trump is out of office so
the entire case is not about
removing him but whether to convict
and disqualify him from holding any
office like the presidency
forever this is huge and has never
actually happened before
the united states senate deciding
something that can shape history
sanction trump and ensure he never has
power again
and do so on that basis that you see
right there
for life there's no more significant
amount of time than for life
that's why nicki minaj famously sang for
life
for life and if the work is vindicated
best believe when it's done
it will be syndicated for life for life
and just as nikki declared herself in
this very moment a king
the question here is if the speaker will
ultimately slay goliath
with a constitutional sling
that well i mean what can i say that's a
great minaj quote uh
personally and i mean don't don't
we all quote that all the time classic
classic personally though the one that i
find myself quoting often is from her
great song uh and
you even know what i'm going to say
barbie tings uh which is
one of the great songs and you know how
it goes but i always find myself saying
this
in just situations throughout life um
she says i love this so much because of
how deeply it resonates with me in my
life
she says it's time to make hits and it's
time to diss
how you still dissin still can't find
some hits
was it worth it dummy i ain't mind a bit
still on that show getting no chips
time to dip i
i i i i i i'm still fly
just bag the white guy richie light guy
and i still eat tai
want the nikki cheat code come on nice
try let's be real
all you [ __ ] want to look like me so
that you know for me
so the guy in msnbc you know we just we
all have different minaj lyrics that we
we love to quote uh it's it's there's
nothing weird about that at all i mean
this guy he wanted to make a point
about the fact that for life is a long
time
and he wanted a quote about i don't know
life being long
first thing he thought was nicki minaj
who who among us who among us wouldn't
have done the same in that exact same
situation
all right number five finally this this
video has gone viral um
it's a very important video almost as
important as nicki minaj and i want to
play this for you
uh because you know i i don't like it i
know i do a lot of cancelling myself on
this show and i'll be canceling someone
coming up in just a moment but
also based on a viral video but uh you
know i i don't believe
in in unfair cancellations and i think
there's an unfair cancellation happening
here
this is a woman i don't know who it is i
don't know the context okay but it's a
woman giving her recipe
for how to class up a bowl of
spaghettios
and she kind of makes this spaghettio
pie this is people are
she is getting let's let's let's just
take a look at this video she is getting
demolished for this
so she's got the spaghettios in a pie
crust
and then she takes she takes some bread
and butters it down real nice
puts a whole lot of butter on the bread
this is her recipe i think this is what
she does for her kids
and then she takes garlic powder and she
just
she's a tons of garlic powder
all over the bread now this is the one
part here that i that maybe is a little
bit
hard to stomach she actually smashes the
bread down with her arms and her hands
she's she's
she's never heard of a rolling pin i
guess maybe she doesn't have one so she
uses her hands
doesn't her hands her arms don't look
too hairy so maybe that's not so bad
and then she she cuts all the crust off
and okay
now she's got the she's got the smashed
down garlic bread and then she puts some
mozzarella cheese on the spaghettios in
the pie crust a whole bunch of mods and
that's the expensive mozzarella cheese
too so she's not no no no no uh
spare no expense here she's she uses
like an eight dollar
bag of cheese puts more garlic on the uh
spaghettios
and then she's gonna put the bread oh
then she puts milk in
okay she puts milk in the spaghettios
and now she's gonna put and she mixes it
together oh and then she puts more
spaghettios on top of it
and then she puts the bread on top of
the spaghettios
the garlic bread and bakes it and i
think there's a follow-up video where
she actually cuts the
the pie and like serves it like a pie
and here's my thing okay this is all i'm
gonna say
um people are saying this looks like a
just a big bowl of vomit and it's it's
the most horrific video they've ever
seen on the internet and there's been a
lot of disturbing videos on the internet
so that's saying something
i just want to say you we both know
that actually looks kind of good
first of all it there's not much you can
do with spaghettios so can you think of
a better way to class up some
spaghettios
spaghettios already are basically
inedible so can you think of a better
way to make spaghettios edible
this is the most noble attempt anyone
has ever made
to make spaghettios edible and also
basically look we know if you add garlic
powder and cheese to pretty much
anything
it'll be okay put some bread add some
more uh carbs to it makes it a little
better too
i'll tell you one thing my kids would
destroy that my kids would love that and
i would uh you know i would eat it too i
think we all would
let's stop pretending okay
let's stop pretending to have fancier
taste than we really do
the spaghettio garlic pie i will defend
it i will say for that
not cancelled now a quick word from rock
otto you know we're all
looking for what are the things we're
looking for especially as customers
we're looking for
ways to save time and save money that's
what we want to do as customers anyway
right
uh you know i think as a customer that's
not a time for like stopping and
smelling the roses you just want to get
in get out get what you need get it for
as cheap as possible at least that's how
i am as a customer if you're the same
way
then you gotta try out rockauto.com
rockauto.com is so much easier than
getting in your car driving to a a store
you know there might be problems
depending on what kind of part you need
for your car you might not be able to
get to the to the auto parts store but
whether you can or not
the fact is you're going to go in there
they might not have what you need and if
they do have it
it's probably going to be more expensive
than it needs to be
that's why you got to try out
rockauto.com you have access to it
at your desk in your pocket rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear their family
business they've been doing this online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts for from
hundreds of manufacturers
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts
that are available for your vehicle and
you can choose the brands the
specifications the prices you prefer
uh and most likely the price you're
gonna prefer is the is
the best one that's the least how i go
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now and see the parts available for your
car or truck right walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you also
um daily wire you know we are what are
we doing we're taking back the culture
and we're doing that starting with
entertainment content we've got a lot of
big plans for dailywire.com coming up in
the year
year ahead in the years ahead a lot that
we want to do but that starts with
getting into the entertainment space and
that started with
run hide fight which is our new um
feature film which was just released and
if you're not a daily wire member yet
but you want to watch this movie which
you really should want to watch it
use promo code rhf to get 25 off that's
rhf for 25 off
we picked run hide fight after hollywood
students studios turned down
the quote distasteful subject matter
because didn't include leftist talking
points
we picked it up um and you know early
critic reviews were pretty negative but
once we released it for you guys the
audience came in and said no hold on a
second this is a good movie
and also it's been interesting that that
now the critic reviews are even ticking
up a little bit
um i think because the critics are you
know realizing maybe that they got it
wrong the first time
so you got to check out run hide fight
if you're not a daily wire member yet
again use promo code
rhf to get 25 off that's rhf for 25
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we have
another parent on tick tock to cancel
um i've selected this one as a
representative of a larger problem it's
not that she individually is deserving
of cancellation
i mean she is and richly so but the
issue is the greater cultural
phenomenon on display which we will
discuss
this is from a woman who goes by the
handle cat might be funny
and she is funny i can report though
perhaps not in the way she intended
and along with the video is a caption
that reads this level of vulnerability
is not
comfy for me hashtag parenting hashtag
moms of tick tock
parents of tick tock lgbtq
mental health yes we're at the point
where
people put hashtag mental health to
accompany videos of their own mental
breakdowns
so let's uh let's check this out i've
just been yelling in my car
for 30 minutes because
parenting is hard
it's hard
because they're little mirrors
if if i want my
son to be a better person
or to grow up and just be a good human
i have to be a good person
he mimics everything i do he mirrors
everything so if i have a bad attitude
he's gonna have a bad attitude if i say
of course he's gonna say
i have to change me to change him
there you go you know i was just waiting
uh much like you probably i was waiting
for the camera to pan back
and her kid is sitting in the back seat
apparently he's not so that's good
although it does raise the question
who's watching her kid while she yells
in her car for 30 minutes
i'm not gonna jump to conclusions i just
maybe she hires a babysitter for such
occasions
it's possible she calls up the sitter
like hey um can you come over for an
hour so yeah i just had this psychotic
break i had to go do
uh it's on a calendar scheduled so okay
see when you get here
i don't know i don't know how it works
exactly more to the point
what we really have to consider are two
things right context and content
and i mean this is what this is what i
factor in anytime i'm deciding on a
cancellation this is this is the product
this is i'm bringing you into my
process right now and in this case it's
the context
not the content that gets her canceled
so on that end the context
here is that she is filming and posting
the video of herself
crying and screaming about how hard it
is to be a parent
this has become a very common genre of
internet videos in fact
you know if internet videos were
distributed old school at like a
blockbuster video
and you had to go into the store to
browse and rent the video you want
the genre of women crying in their cars
would take up like
five entire rows uh it would be like
what it used to be
at blockbuster when you go in the the uh
the action and adventure
section was the best section that was
almost half the store and that but now
it would be women
crying in their cars but why would you
do this
if you're having a desperate personal
moment
where a crushing existential realization
has come rushing in and you are reduced
to screams and tears because of it
happens to the best of us
but why would you want to film it and
turn it into a spectacle
for strangers like myself to gawk at and
laugh at
why would you even think to do that the
answer is that you do it because you
lack the capacity for a true
inner life okay it's a little bit too
simple to say oh they want attention i
mean they do want attention
but i think the problem is deeper than
that because in the modern age many
people have
outsourced their inner life their in
their their internal
dialogue to the internet i'm convinced
this is why
we spend so much time on the internet in
the first place it's why when you're in
the checkout line or waiting for an oil
change or an elevator or anywhere else
everyone around you is just on their
phone the whole time
never looking up not at all present in
the moment
they can't stand to have a moment of
stillness a moment of inactivity a
moment of silence because then they
start to think
think their own thoughts for a change
and that becomes too much to bear so
they retreat to cyberspace again
to escape themselves to escape their own
minds so this woman is in the midst of
what could have been had she not
involved the entire world in it
a really profound and painful and
important episode in her life it's a
confrontation with
with harsh realities and occasion to
feel to really feel
guilt and accountability and shame and
determination all of these emotions that
are heavy to bear but
could also be invigorating and
motivating and clarifying
could have been a very human moment and
she was
in it experiencing it but she pulled
back retreated and decided to use it
as content instead decided to reduce it
to spectacle
and once it's a spectacle it immediately
loses the meaning it could have had
and the impact it could have had for you
and on you
there's there's something quite
beautiful and human about
having a moment of great emotional
impact uh
an awakening of sorts and then uh i
think that the kids would call it a red
pill and then
and then not telling a single soul
about it just keeping it within
letting it seep deep into yourself
letting it be
you don't tell anybody it's just for you
forever
nobody else we should have many such
moments as humans
did you know that we don't realize this
now there should be many
thoughts that we think and never tell
anyone many emotions we feel and never
announce
to anyone but now nothing is private
nothing is sacred nothing is personal
nothing is left for the individual
to hold within and ponder all is just
spewed out into the public as
empty distraction for strangers who
don't really care anyway
what could have been an occasion for
growth has instead become an occasion to
attract attention and not even
meaningful attention
but the cheapest and most pointless kind
of it
and that's why she's canceled and that's
why all women crying in their cars and
filming it are cancelled
and it's why all of us on the internet
are canceled for being a part of this
problem to one extent or the other
all that said i do also have to
acknowledge that the content was
actually correct
um one of the hardest realizations for a
parent
is that is that you know you're really
being pretty ridiculous
when you get angry at your kids i mean
that's what you have to realize at a
certain point as a parent like you
really you almost never have any
legitimate reason to be angry at your
kids it's hard to justify anger at your
child
when you consider three facts about them
one
they have significant neurological
limitations nothing you or they can do
about that number two
they are acting exactly as you did at
their age and number three this is the
hardest of all this is what she's
dealing with
they're acting as you do now too
so if you're impatient and prone to
shouting your kid will be the same if
you're disorganized and messy your kid
will be the same
if you use bad language as she mentioned
your kid will do the same
you really have no right to be mad at
them for doing and behaving exactly as
you do
if anything they should be mad at you
for setting such a bad example
and then for having the gall to expect
more of your child than you expect of
yourself
because that's the truth if you are
again let's say to use an example that
hits very close to home for me
an impatient person and then you get mad
at your kid for being impatient
then you are quite literally expecting
your whatever
nine-year-old to be a better person than
you
and when you think about it like that it
well it makes you feel even worse
and that's when the parenting guilt
spiral begins and you start falling down
it and you start thinking yourself my
god i'm a failure i'm not cut out for
this i'm a horrible person and you start
crying in your car
which again all that's fine just don't
film it
the good news is um i guess if we can
call it that
is that every parent is guilty of
getting mad at their kids
for doing stuff that they themselves did
and still do
because while your child has limitations
by virtue of being a child
you also have limitations by virtue of
being human that doesn't excuse your
failures as a parent but it does mean
that you might as well skip over the
self-pity and guilt trip and just get
back to work trying to be a better
person a better example a better parent
than you have been
because we're all trying to scratch and
call crawl our way through this mostly
blind
we're all kind of making it up as we go
along
that's another realization you have as a
parent you start you start thinking back
to your own parents when you know when
you were your kids
age and you realized oh they had no idea
what the hell they were doing either
that's why there are a billion parenting
books on the market
and they all sell a million copies each
because all
parents if they have any self-awareness
or intelligence will reach a point where
they say holy crap i have no idea what
i'm doing
and that's when they run out looking for
the how-to manual like someone
give me someone tell me how to do this
but we're wasting our money
when we buy those books because the real
parenting how to the real
guide is what we already know
it's just we have trouble implementing
it because it's hard basically just
be a better person be more patient be
more kind have more discipline
set a better example that's really it
like that's it right
and at that point comes yet another
epiphany which is this
wait no i do know how to be a better
parent
parenting is simple the problem is that
i want to be a parent
and raise good kids well-behaved kids
well-adjusted kids
without making the prerequisite changes
to myself
and my own behavior and lifestyle that's
where all of my problems are coming from
as a parent
that just doesn't work you got to make
the changes to yourself
it sounds like the woman in the video
was arriving at this conclusion
and she should be commended for that i
mean that sincerely
but she's still canceled because she
filmed it
and there's just no excuse for that
and uh on that note a little bit of a
bittersweet
commended yet still canceled that can
happen
happens sometimes we'll leave it there
for today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show the media pushed
president biden as the most normal
normal person who has ever normaled in
the history of normalcy but there is
only one problem is policy
not normal that's today on the ben
shapiro show join us